We're going to radically
rethink the design of sunshine.
Before we dive into this further,
let me make it clear that
there are many positive things
about the sunshine design.
Particularly the portrait phone model.
The landscape version, however,
is very clearly a stretched
version of the portrait design.
The giant blue splash for the today view
is a nice idea, but it's a bit too much,
especially in landscape.
The use of roboto condensed, detracts
from the appeal of these reviews.
The detail views even on
a phone start to fall down.
It's a pretty simplistic presentation
with uneven use of white space.
The landscape version even,
needs to scroll to show all content.
For the portrait forecast view,
we're going to moving toward better
use of color and white space.
Even though we're initially using
up more space with the app bar.
We're going to add some code to
allow us to scroll it along with
the forecast list.
For the landscape view,
we're doing something pretty radical in
order to improve the use of white space.
Namely we've eliminated
most of the app bar.
By taking the sides of the list in.
We provide more balance to this layout.
It's not ideal but
it's more aesthetically pleasing.
We'll also demonstrate some
parallax scrolling here.
For the detail view we're
doing a more serious overhaul.
We're using a toolbar that matches
the coloring of the detail view.
And only contains share functionality.
The bottom includes a nice accent shade
with a separate section of the app per
data unique to the detail view.
Overall, it's a far
better use of whitespace.
And a good teaching ground for
some more advanced layout techniques.
The landscape detail view is even more
striking in comparison to the original
application.
It not only has a nice look.
It actually fits more
information on the screen.
The landscape tablet version
wouldn't make it on google
play as a tablet optimized application
with all that unused space.
We'll give it a fresh
look with the update.
Our portrait tablet is even more
striking in its comparative use of
white space.
If the challenge to display an app
which has list like this and tablet's.
Without falling into confusing
user scenarios such as
changing the number of fragments on
screen between portrait and landscape.
We'll dive deeper into implementing
this design throughout the lesson.